[Music]
cargo is a 2018 post-apocalyptic zombie
movie starring Martin Freeman the
Netflix original film follows Freeman's
character Andy as he has caught his
daughter Rosie across the Australian
outback left with only 48 hours before
he transforms into his aam be and he
must find a new Guardian for his child
throughout this video I will be
discussing cargoes ending as well as
what I think caused the viral outbreak
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
in this video so I highly recommend that
you give this omits if you want to go
into the film with fresh eyes with that
out the way I'm definition and this is
my ending explain video for car calls
after being attacked by a zombie when
searching for supplies on a yacht Andy's
wife is in dire need of health infected
by a virus that causes mucus to pour
from all orifices uncontrollable spasms
and an eventual transition into the
undead she seems like a lost cause
however the family man refuses to give
up on her and sets out looking for help
with his partner and daughter while it's
driving across the Australian wilderness
in an attempt to find a hospital and he
crashes the car and when trying to
unbuckle his daughter he is bitten by
his infected wife humans carrying the
disease normally have a 48-hour window
before the virus takes over but due to
the crash Andy's wife dies prematurely
and transforms from this point onward
continuing his journey to the hospital
for medical aid and he encounters to me
this Aborigine girl is a water her
infected father and even though her
family are looking for her she refuses
to return to them Andy devastated with
his wife's passing and anxious over the
fact that his days are numbered leaves
the girl to her own devices and searches
for someone to take care of his child on
the road here in Canada
Vick and after saving his life Andy is
given shelter invited hunting by Vick he
quickly discovers that his new ally is
in fact using to me and BAE in order to
loot the corpses of the undead
this affects Andy to no end and that
night he attempts suicide Vic's
quote-unquote girlfriend lorraine stops
him and when Vick stumbles across the
two talking in the dead of night he
suspects that they are having an affair
and turns on Andy Andy awakes in the
cage with two me but by using his wits
manages to escape with the girl they
returned to the camp in order to save
the rain who earlier on tried to make
Andy aware of Vicks true nature but she
is shot in the process and they flee
into the night with less than 24 hours
to live and he sets out with to me to
find the girl's family and it's a
harrowing journey there are several
run-ins with zombies and humans alike
and the three barely make it through the
ordeal aware that he is near death and
erupts fraught and flesh onto his stick
and pics to me up to me sticks the flesh
rot out in front of Andy and similar to
a carrot on a stick with a donkey he
takes to me back to her family reunited
with her family to me is taken to an
outback paradise where Rosie can be
safely raised we see Andy's shirt
hanging on a tree with a bunch of
branches and bark surrounding his body
for the final shot and this is a motif
of an Aboriginal funeral showing that he
was accepted and thanked by Timmy's
family it's a fitting end for the
character and a bittersweet moment at
tops of this brilliant film when
theorizing what caused the zombie
outbreak one must first examine the
symptoms that the infected display the
most notable is the fact that they dig
holes into the ground and bury their
head into them in the animal kingdom
similarities can be found in the
parasitic organism of horse hair where
its creature infects insects and causes
them to commit suicide or act in an
extremely peculiar way initially their
larvae is laid upon the bottom of rivers
but as they are unable
to swim they must wait to be eaten
during their digestion period typically
crickets mosquitoes and other pond life
they will eventually drive their host to
leap to their death into water and where
they can then hatch from the abdomen and
continue their cycle of life the
horsehair worm even goes so far as to
stop the cricket from making its
stereotypical chirping noise in order to
avoid detection from other animals
it does not want its hosts to be harmed
under any circumstances I believe that
the infected are driven by parasites
that are subterranean earth creatures
this is backed up by the fact that
throughout the film
there are several posters and
paraphernalia that mentioned fracking
fracking is the process of ejecting
liquid at high pressure into
subterranean rocks and bore holes so as
to Falls open existing fissures and
extract oil or gas this constant mining
of the earth could have disturbed the
parasite and caused it to rise to the
surface this would explain why the
infected are constantly attempting to
dig back into the dirt and seek out
darkness which environmentally would be
similar to their habitat and to me it's
the only explanation I'd love to hear
your thoughts and theories on what has
caused a zombie outbreak so please leave
them in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel as I post
anything explained videos across a wide
range of media and there will definitely
be something on the channel that you
love I recently discussed the ending of
Deadpool 2 as well as God of War and you
can check those videos out linked at the
end of this one thanks very much for
taking the time to watch this I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]